Coronavirus is dealing the Chinese
economy a very serious blow. The scope of
the virus' impact has already far
exceeded the 2003 SARS epidemic. This has
led to the virtual shutdown of China, the
world's second largest economy. That, in turn,
has disrupted global supply chains,
led to the collapse in international
commodity prices, and caused major
disruptions to the world travel industry.
The marked slowing in the Chinese economy
is coming at a very bad time for the global
economy. Already before coronavirus, the
Japanese and German economies were
heading for recessions, Latin America was
being beset by widespread social unrest,
and the Indian economy was grinding to a
halt. Unless the corona virus epidemic is
soon brought under control, it is likely
that global economic conditions will
only worsen. That's bound to reach US
shores and bound to make a difficult for
China to meet its commitments under the
US-China phase one trade deal.
Unfortunately, it's far from clear that
the coronavirus epidemic is anywhere
near to being under control. How do you
think the corona virus will affect the
world's economy? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI